Salar why now in terms of longevity
what's happened to make you raise a fund
and start investing in research and
companies yeah so we think this is an
insanely important part of the story
because if you were aristotle and you
were like trying to start longevity fund
you would have a terrible time really
for the worst idea and and so timing is
super important like why now for the
first time in like 2000 3000 years of
the correct time to work on longevity to
us a lot of that comes back to tooling
and what's available for us to use hmm
no prior to the 1900s if you wanted to
impact biology you know maybe you should
have been a physicist you know worked on
optics helped make the first microscope
and like Robert Hooke a physicists you
know it discovers the cell so you know
there's so much that comes from physics
and other disciplines into biology to
push it forward but then I think in the
1900s something kind of fascinating
happens which is that for the first time
there's kind of this acceleration of
tooling right x-rays NMR all these
things you know the cathode ray tube
discovered mass spectrometry but if you
know by this guy trying to find a mass
of electron which is so cool and so all
these physics tools starting to coming
online but they're also more biology
driven tools and and so really I think
you know and we can get into this more
specifically maybe your time but kind of
what's excited us is just seeing the
tools available to characterize like
life become available for the first time
ever right you know for all millennia
you had Darwin and like Mendel talked
about genetics and like there is no
knowledge of what was actually going on
at the ground truth level and in 1953
for the first time you have like the
link between molecular biology and
looking with microscopes and like
genetics and like this you know sort of
concept of fredda T which is just super
exciting and what caused you to jump in
well I mean I think was born like a very
lucky time would you I think you always
had to be you know sort of cautious or
like I guess like a little bit concerned
if you believe that about yourself right
like why now like I'm you know should
you really be lucky time but then I
think also you know as a kid or a just
like had a lot of relatives that were
you know sort of aging and that was very
striking but also you know really wanted
to solve cancer and I
I remember talking to my dad about this
and I was like Oh thinking I want to
solve cancer he's like well you know
cancer is a subset of aging so if you
want to solve cancer you just like you
know solve a teaching it like takes care
of all these other things as well and
that just ain't of that a couple kind of
like hang off my grandma like they're
just gonna made sense to music kiddos
like okay well like you guess I'll go
solve aging then problem because cancer
is not the number one cause of death in
the u.s. right it's heart disease great
what just like if you look all the HLA
diseases you know pastor and point are
driving kind of like the majority of
sort of natural deaths so to speak so
you know like you know once we got rid
of infectious disease like it really
became the case like aging which wasn't
previously like it necessarily the
biggest issue sort of like rose to the
forefront
yeah um and so that that kind of I mean
they're just I think made sense to like
a small trials that that was important
huh and so why raise a fund rather than
you know just go go for curing cancer so
so the thinking at the time was you know
possibly in a good way like emperor has
no clothes like extremely simplistic
like um you have to understand so I was
at MIT and I was like a sophomore yeah
and I was also 16 and I had like maybe a
thousand dollars in my bank account and
so like you know knowledge about like
the financial industry like also below
my dad had been in public investors so I
kind of knew a lot about like the idea
of investing in things like that was a
generally good thing to do and I'd
worked in like Aging labs for maybe four
years and I think the the striking thing
was just like there there was just like
no money to like make drugs and it's
kind of hard you know like when you're
in a lab you have like no idea what's
going on in the outside world and so I
would like ask venture capitalists like
I'd you know call up a few in the phone
book like you know a few responded and
so like have these like random
conversations and just be like you know
I'm just curious I'm a student he like
tell me more about like how this
industry works like you know are you
funding aging therapeutics and like none
of them had heard of like aging
therapeutics they're kind of like Asian
therapeutics and so that was just very
striking that like something that I
personally believe like on the
technologies like not just like you from
a mission perspective like on the
technology side was like super exciting
was kind of generally not really like
looked at a lot by these folks who were
supposedly like the great translators of
technology and I think also it kind of
made sense like you know the first ever
mutation found to really sended where my
Stein was 1983 the next was like 1993
and so really I feel started about like
20-30 years ago so I kinda made sense
like if you think about like how long
things were fuels like get try
like become known like okay there maybe
like less than a hundred good labs in
this space maybe like people just like
haven't had enough time unlike the
adventure or like investment side to
understand that this is like really cool
and important and so like then it kind
of made sense that like you might want
to sort of find if that were the case
like help more drugs gonna get started
out of the space hmm so in other words
like the big pharmaceutical companies
are not investing in these they were
they weren't at the time seven years ago
yeah the things have really changed
they're you know seven years ago there
were like maybe like three companies
been started or so that had like the
aging brand on them yeah there was like
zero people under like arch ventures we
wanted a few that were like taking risks
there's a maybe ten million invested
like that you're in total it's like this
space right only in the past four years
we've had like ten billion plus we now
see like three hundred companies per
year so it's just really changed like
it's very very striking to watch you go
from like zero to like what it is today
yeah now it's totally a trend yeah it
sticks around so you have a not a
million but many questions for you I
think like top of the list for me is
what you do personal yes this is
probably the most common question yeah
and I think all my friends will always
say that I answer this terribly because
I you know I'm kind of like a you know I
come from a semi scientific background
and so like we like to get like to the
ground truth of things and it's just
really hard like there's just like a
million leave you start reading
mouthsize longevity like you will find
mouth sites that say like if you
decrease like they've done this like
really cool experiment where you take
fat and sugar and and protein and you
decrease the level of each of them and
keep a total calorie and take the same
you can kind of tasks like which
component of diet is like intervene for
longevity and they did this and they
like did kind of like a full matrix and
they'd like lifespan studies for each
like the different proportions yeah and
what they found from that study and mice
was that like decrease in protein was
the number one kind of thing that
increased longevity and so from that you
might infer like maybe less protein is
good but at the same time it doesn't
seem like you know maybe if you work out
a lot that would be different and so I
come to the conclusion that kind of like
you know I have some feces about like
what is good and what is not good but it
just as a scientist it's really hard to
say there's kind of like a good kind of
like real kind of like a couple
hypotheses there okay and so sometimes
you're like not not a lot of like like
not just despite like reading probably
more papers on this than like most
people in the world
yeah
it really is something where I I don't
see things I think are extremely clear
kind of like movers for longevity unlike
a diet level obviously that like are
compounded by other things so what's
your diet um well I've tried a variety
of things I think right now is just kind
of like the sort of like beer a minimal
like try to eat low sugar I'm personally
trying low protein just cuz I think that
is somewhat supported by kind of like
literature yeah and low protein is like
a gram per kilogram per day um I think
it's sort of like not it's it's a good
questions like what what is the correct
per person and also if you exercise yeah
I actually once tried to calculate out
if you exercise like how much protein
would be required to like a pleasure
just like all of your mouse and accent
proteins yeah it's kind of fascinating I
think that that might actually be like
you know up to a hundred fold increase
in power like in your muscles we're like
if they all fired at the same time you
get like you know sort of a lot of power
but any of but I mean I I you know I
just I don't have any strong
recommendations on diet like I really
like I've read basically all the studies
yeah and I think maybe low protein low
sugar are both killer intrument a sting
seems to be like somewhat supported are
you doing that I've tried it I think
it's kind of hard to maintain if you
like you know have a graduating sleep
cycle oh yeah but yeah I wish I had
better recommendations for it for that
for that area okay and in terms of
supplements you doing anything um
there's a variety people or commit
everything from a d-plus all the way
through to like metformin and for the
kind of more adventurous I think that so
we actually a secret list at the fund of
like on market drugs and things that we
think it based on like our like body of
evidence yeah might be having an impact
on life spent and we're monitoring them
some of them I personally think it would
be like intriguing to take we don't
release that list is because we were
afraid that if we did and kind of like
somebody acted on it and kind of like
didn't work out well for them that you
know a terrible thing to do do them but
we have a secret list of things that we
think are like interesting okay and I
but I think for the ninety plus there's
there some evidence of like positive
effect there but we haven't seen quite
like some studies showing like a large
increase in lifespan look I didn't like
my one concern there okay
cool because yeah in in the the
worm and mouse studies therapy I like
you know a hundred percent increase in
lifespan right with certain uh so we're
studies we've gotten up to ten fold
reported you know possibly more that's
by decreasing a gene product though so
that's kind of like if you want to go
into a gene therapy or we had such a
thing you know Polly or from birth
possibly like that would work but but
probably the effectively a lot smaller
and mice we've got about it up to a
two-fold increase and that was a
combination of of a mutation and
restricting the total cork intake of the
mouse okay down to what I don't remember
for that study on average I think people
will do see our to about thirty percent
of normal caloric intake but it really
varies so if you take forty different
and this is where it gets complicated
yeah you take forty different
genetically different strains of mice
and you change their diet in the same
way half Alif shorter and half a live
longer and so you know I used to as a
casserole I was like oh you're like
there's a simple answer and I think that
there is but I think it is a lot more
sort of reliant on genetics and other
things then we'd like to think um hmm
how long of your family family members
lives great grandpa
well my grandma is still going she's
she's in her mid mid 90s um it's good
time yes exactly they've all lived you
know about age 80 or above so you know
hopefully about yourself how long is
your 9 d so yeah we'll see how it goes I
needed more than you right yeah what
would you say the number one health half
that you recommend to your your audience
would be I think well I mean I've done a
little bit of blood work so everything's
kind of anecdotal and based on feel yeah
I was vegetarian for eight years
oh interesting for environmental reasons
and then I realized why I had like
developed this entire vocabulary round
cheating so for example if I was
traveling it was like cultural meet and
it was allowed I was like you know over
over your house and like you made
chicken or something about yeah whatever
I'll have it I see and at the point it
was like twice a month I was like I'm
not vegetarian anymore
so I started eating more protein but
really just more eggs yeah and then I
felt a lot better
but really the main thing is sleep I
think yeah prayers that make sense I
will should actually one thing that's
interesting on the the health spend
front I think people have this like
intuition that when they feel better
that's some martyr that's a metric for
something that's good for them yeah I
think it's actually not true so if you
look like a lot to some extent like you
know maybe you want optimize like robust
very cheerful lifespan in which case
like oli tautologically it is yeah but
most the time a lot of the time when you
see our mice or you do other things like
make them live longer so total number of
years increases they're all kind of like
as happy on a day-to-day basis like a
little bit thinner a little bit more of
the flower jerk in some cases so I think
it's kind like you know whenever someone
says like I really feel better accepting
I'm always like oh gosh like I wonder if
that's like the correct thing like maybe
maybe not when people talk about health
spin in my mind it's very correlated to
how I feel right if I was gonna do
caloric restriction and every day would
suck for 90 years I would opt out I mean
I don't know if there's a drug I for
instance like I know a lot of people who
have experimented with like keto and
other random diets and their caffeinated
to the gills so funny that's one thing
you can do oh my gosh yes hilarious yeah
yeah so I don't know but one thing I've
been curious about like there seems to
be relatively limited data on actual
humans yes so how might someone set up a
set is it even possible now or is
everything's alright there is this
fellow in your bars life who's working
on what's called the the tame trial and
the point of that is to say the effects
of this drug that form which is a very
old diabetes drug yeah on sort of
markers or biomarkers of aging that he
has kind of like put forward and the
costs for that will be about sixty
million dollars and if people do it the
idea would be okay well here's a first
pass at testing Aging in humans and so
finally we have some more data the way
that trial was sort of motivated was
there is these large finding that in
hundreds of thousands of patients or I
think about actually 70,000 that
population from kind of like a UK study
if you look retrospectively people who
had and take him at four hundred decades
they had apparently like a little bit
better kind of health spans so they had
less age-related disease the diabetic
sit on this drug even then they're kind
of like non-diabetic counterparts you
were not taking that for
and so I think it you know heart study
is like an like definitive evidence but
that kind of motivated all the sort of
question asking of you know could we
really nail down and humans a trial to
like test you know Matt med for in
particular that said you know I I think
that a lot of biologists will really
kind of you know say oh it's very
important to test things in humans and
of course it is you could do that we
would be doing it all over the place um
but I think increasingly over the years
and maybe it's just like I started out
in world biology I'm kind of like more
and more excited about like the animal
kingdom like you know the animal kingdom
is just like absolutely awesome like we
have one company and our you know
current sort of you know sort of poor
flurry that's working on this and
they're amazing yo fauna um but kind of
like it's like there's such diversity of
phenotypes right and like how can we
learn from other animals suppose just
like our lowly selves because like you
know for example there's naked mole rats
and rats or like naked mole rats are
pushing 30 on life span like we have no
idea how long they live let their
mortality rate at 30 s not going up so
we're just like watching these guys like
waiting for them to start dying and then
like rats which have like very similar
physiology live maybe like three to four
years and so what our earth is different
between these two animals right like
that's just absolutely fascinating I
think it's also important because like
you know you you a lot of like your
physician mathematicians and that I used
to be this way like we're always worried
or there's like inherent like limitation
on like the complexity level are like
what if given a certain complex system I
start reading metabolism like you have
to die because there's some kind of like
you know sort of theory about like
entropy increasing over time and that
like you know must dry and just like to
complex like really intervene but then
like even these animals are basically
the same size like have so like so many
other similarities like it would just be
very hard to maintain like that theory
and also accept this kind of like large
differential longevity yeah absolutely
so someone asked the question that I
thought was kind of funny yeah here we
go so Mike asks basically do you think
immortality is going to be achieved by
curing all diseases so in other words
like the forever or like what's gonna
happen first that or are we gonna just
upload our consciousness to a computer
and live forever that way I think that
so that that is a question that I used
to get very interested in sort of like
well you know if you really care about
that's like you're working on kind of
all do yeah where do you work you
exactly I think so the way the the way I
kind of think about it which is not a
good answer but it's like a frame
thinking about this question is I think
about biology like a set of tools right
so you and you can you can kind of see
this in like the kind of like things
that have become available recently for
us to use to affect human health what I
mean by that is like you know prior to
like you know the nineteen hundreds or
really like even like just the 1980s or
mainly the nineteen thirties the first
time you look at this marker if you
wanted to make a drug it was like a
small molecule right you got a plant
you found something from a plot that was
useful yeah or you like put some salt in
a wound we realize that's a bad idea
don't do that not very not very good for
sterility there are things you do but
then like you know in the 20 century for
the first time we use like proteins
you know insulin or antibodies created
by like our own bodies or the Flies like
the mice that like we kind of need to
clone them in um to treat disease and so
we actually use something that came from
life to treats you know kind of like a
living organism we now just in the past
kind of three years have like landmark
approvals and viruses being used to like
blow up cancer literally like these are
called all Kalitta kairos --is there's
new drugs using genetic engineered cells
you've probably heard of you know Carty
and kinda like this whole kind of you
know ecology phenomenon also stem cells
being used and so i think i don't like
the final frontier of all of that like
use of connect biologies own system to
do cool stuff
is the brain understanding kind of like
that system but i think to lead up to
that you kind of will do so many things
that it may be the case that like we
kind of get there the same time right so
you know that's like the final frontier
and we solve it become like along the
wave also kind of like done enough work
on the other tooling kind of fronts that
we get to kinda like to a kind of um you
know maybe we don't solve kind of like a
lifespan itself but like when Giambi's
definitely impacted but kinda like they
work up to that
up to that time right exactly in do you
sense that there's like a strong signal
at this point as to what might be the
way that we you know a bunch of people
ask these questions but increasing
lifespan like 20 percent like right if
you had to put money on obviously you
literally put money on it like what
would be the most likely thing to take
off the most likely thing to do in the
next 50 years so here's how we think
about it like we have extremely strong
confidence that it's possible impact
lifespan between like you know three
months to maybe ten years yeah and you
know obviously like you know different
probabilities with all we have to
we're pretty certain that there are some
things in the clinic already or on the
market that with some probability are
impacting lifespan right like your
lifespan seems to be very malleable you
know to a small degree I think the
larger question is like well you know a
how many of those can be like put
together to like get kind of the maximal
impact from like that first wave and
then be our thesis is that none of those
things will be sufficient on their own
to results like an engineered lifespan
so you have this first wave of things
like kind of work but like they're kind
of limited like they have kind of like a
it may be like sixty percent and that's
like the max so then the question is
like how can you like go above that and
we can that really all comes back to
tooling and so that's where I don't know
if I'm you know we're Aristotle or kind
of like we're with Newton or like maybe
like in the best case scenario were like
Einstein or like you know of someone
today and in the realm of physics in
terms like going to the moon I'm like
you've tried to go to the moon and kind
of like sixteen hundreds would be a
little bit hard uh more recently maybe a
little bit easier but like I think
that's where we have we have some hope
and optimism but we're not as confident
that there are things today that would
point you to say that's the result some
kind of like unbounded engineered
ability to kind of like impact longevity
and that's why we also really care about
about tools and we think about like
investing in the space not just kind of
the first wave of like awesome therapies
that will be available sooner but like
maybe aren't is kind of like engineer
able right so you're kind of hedging if
this is still a foundational stage right
exactly I think we'd love to think that
it is only I think yeah 1953 my argument
for foundational seems to be like this
is the first time ever in history that
we have the link between genetics in
melka biology that happened 1953 that's
pretty landmark maybe it's been 70 years
you're like well what happened and so
you couldn't just have happen like right
after 1953 but I think that be the
argument for like that's why today makes
sense from it like engineering
perspective okay um-hmm and then
ethically you know Ryan Hoover asks like
about the ethics of longevity another
Jack Fernandez Ashley people want to
actually want to live longer
right you do you have strong opinions on
this or you yes
stepping back so we get we get asked
about this all the time and it was folks
when I started the fund I never thought
that people would ask those questions
yeah you kiss to me the reason you
thought it was assumed well because the
week we started the fund was secured
like things like cancer and Alzheimer's
and so like from our perspectives like
well you know like you never asked like
is it good to cure cancer like no one
would ever ask that question that I've
heard of or maybe some people would but
then we realize that like the
people think longevity they think about
it as different than those things and so
I think like you know from our
perspective like that I just you know I
think it makes sense to cure Kelly pcs
if we can and so we definitely wanted to
do that and so like you know we would
never deviate from kind of our mission I
think you know from a broader scale it's
kind of like two camps alike do you want
to be like Malthusian and you're
thinking it kind of like no the world is
like a bounded place like you know it's
really like limited resources were like
kind of like David Deutsch in like you
know like you know we're no spaceship
birth but like no we're not actually
like let's go at least for the cosmos
and kind like in limited resources and
energies like it all matter I think we
just like it kind of like it from a like
philosophically end point I'm more on
the kind of a ladder sort of camp I just
like that kind of viewpoint a little bit
better
but yeah I think to us like just the the
rationale for longevity really was
let's curate to lay diseases how you do
that you work on Aging hmm and then
maybe there are multiple universes
I'm trying to get yeah yeah
would you have to like go to him and his
that's what I did when I met him yeah he
did run the same hair so it was kind of
cool oh my gosh but but really like in
terms of having an actual opinion on
this so there was a cool one on the
ethics my caste
how would immortality change society
wouldn't we become more complacent since
we have to quote forever to do things
wouldn't that diminish our rate of
innovation and since the less new
individuals are being created we would
have less access to new ideas
in other words like there are fewer
Newton's your Einsteins and and sort of
this is like yeah why the the basic
income are you or one of the basic
income arguments right right laughs for
these people to succeed well so I think
there are two implicit assumptions there
one is that we understand how people are
motivated and that their motivation
stems from this feeling that like they
will die yeah I think number two is this
idea that like people have an innate
kind of rate of loss of new ideas with
age kind of innate like loss of openness
and I think that you know addressing
both those on the first points but kind
of all questions I don't I just I I
don't think that that's true personally
I don't think that like I'm motivated to
do things because like I know that I'm
going to die like I think that you know
perhaps everyone else's and this is kind
of personal thinking I think I'm
motivated by many things like curiosity
competition sort of like you know
personal growth kind of like wanting to
be like better next year than like no
was today kind of like a sense of
mission and importance kind of like you
know it support to go do certain things
and and you know I think if you ask most
people I you know maybe they'd have
different answers but I just you know
I'm curious if like death really it
really is like the core kind of like
motivator to do things for everyone else
like that that's one thing and my result
and few people want to go to war which
might be problematic if you kind of like
want to know more and more soldiers or
or not if you would like less war
interesting thing but I think for that
question I just I don't I don't agree
that we really understand like the core
motivation to everyone's planet and that
that is by its or definition and the
fear of death um I think the other thing
that's interesting is sort of to the
second points the question of like loss
mode use the age there is a lot of like
just cognitive like change with age
which is very fascinating right sort of
like you know biologically you do change
and like you part of what we like really
want to do you know is impact aging but
like a large part of it because make a
cognitive enhancer you were like sharp
until you're nine and then you you know
dropped like that would be equally like
that's else would be like an awesome
product and of itself like just calling
an enhancement like the loan would be
great and so I think I think actually
people kind of like undercounting the
value potentially if you're a Newton
absolute brilliance and you help develop
a field and maintain your
twenty-year-old openness and kind of
like fluidity 401 let's go to Asia 90
yeah like what insane kind of ideas we
can even be coming up with at age 90
yeah like where that kind of openness
the counter-argument there is like well
he would just go into alchemy and
something you have like you know young
noon being great and I'm like Walter
Newton like doing alchemy little
counter-argument is like well maybe I'll
come you like cause the date client and
thinking because like you Stefan too
much mercury yeah you almost won an
argument for like outsider scientists
who don't get discovered until they die
and then they have like 100 years of
portfolio breeze and they're also just I
mean like so many people like you know
some incredible forces at Stanford who
are still amazing and coming with
extremely nobody's like you know Hawking
publishing on like black holes and
trophies right like this final paper
yeah like on this completely novel
fascinating field yeah unlike was that
like you know was he declining would we
like Hawking to kind of like step aside
like the younger generation like can't
we have both I guess would be a question
interesting so would you be a proponent
of like you know giving the entire like
somewhat like fluoride in the water
putting like provigil in the water I
think that I'm never a fan of things
that don't involve individual choice
so anything that like would be sort of
coercive or kind of like enforcement's
then like no but I mean it's really
exciting sign up for it then like I do
think that you know there's like all
this fascinating work on economy of
enhanced like just trying to come out
today and and that's a we used a lot of
companies that were super excited about
the have to do kind of like you know
making your neurons kind of like make
more sunlight such like increasingly
they're like rate of division or you
know hypothetic I think that a really
contentious but you know like that to us
it's kind of like that's part of
longevity I mean if we just had a pill
Fork like cognitive enhancement you know
that itself would be like absolutely
wonderful yeah I mean everything I've
tried it's yeah it works there's some
times where you get this feeling that
you're you know you're really good at
like you're crushed an email but you're
not and you're just like sweating the
whole day not thoughts yeah yeah dr.
Foster I remember this book I'm daily
habits know I would actually record a
lee habits of mostly writers and artists
okay um but it's super fast things and
details like how they lived their life
and it's just extremely variable but I
think the most common thing is that they
all wake up and go to sleep Utley have a
very set routine and when they wake up
to you work and go to sleep I'm already
on that cycle yeah I mean what a thing I
have found is that my um my mornings are
just much more valuable than my evenings
yes especially in the middle of the day
I think I'm just kind of useless so I
just worry about it like 2:00 in the
afternoon I'm curious why that is like
it's either biological or psychological
or I sort of like you know you get like
too much loaded into your brain you
don't want a thing or it'd be really
fascinating if sleep played a key role
there I would sort of like sleep does
something biologically and perhaps like
a logical like somehow and doose's like
an optimal state like right when you
wake up but yeah have you tried it like
sleeping in the middle of the day and
then just getting back to work I haven't
but that's an interesting idea
yeah what that would do possible
interest yeah I'm so curious about
cognitive enhancement and that we did a
podcast with Rosalyn Watts who is an
imperial about psychedelics Oh
we're awesome I mean it's it's very
similar actually her research with Robin
Carhart Harris at Imperial is in Michael
Pollan's book saying no I did I've heard
so much about it though it's really
great but I mean it's kind of like
cognitive hint enhancement in a very
broad sense it was like trying to break
you out of your old habits and like have
more confidence increase openness and
yeah exactly and so are you are you
taking anything to like any in nootropic
since um no I think I don't even do
caffeine because the general thought
it's like try to wean yourself off of
everything kind of like if you can
perform great there then like perhaps
some day like it'll be a safe know that
comes our market that's that's worth
worth trying but um yeah I also like I
like Marcus realist like Stowe this is
like idea I've kind of like you know
none of the necessary things but like me
doesn't miss application of a small
sweet I think about it yeah some part of
that just makes me angry like I just
really wanna well it's like it all you
know kind of like the cork I'm ice I
don't know I'm a I'm a dichotomy like
it's it's all stretched apart because
I'm very much creature of habit okay
that being said I like caloric
restriction not having like a beer with
my friends like all this stuff yeah
don't I'm not doing it
I'd rather huh I'd rather work out an
extra time but then but then some people
say like that's bad for your heart right
you know yeah so I don't know I feel
like in some ways it's like the devil I
know and I just avoid other vices like
texting while driving and smoking that's
interesting mmm-hmm
what does like the thing that you do
that you're the most proud of like the
habit that is like hard for you to
maintain that you nevertheless are
clinically quite happy to like be able
to do I mean exercise is no problem
because I go I go crazy without doing it
right I think what's consistently the
hardest to maintain is giving energy to
the side projects that are creatively
demanding oh that's interesting
because I this is what I didn't expect I
used to work for myself and now I work
oh I see and obviously and there are
obviously like you you have so much
energy in the day and obviously you can
like push harder and get work done and
like be more disciplined but I found
that like there are certain side project
ideas that are just kind of like too
much to even think about oh interesting
so I'm yeah like when I when I make
progress on that I'm very happy with
myself because the side projects that
are like you know I've like may like
little sass tools and stuff and that's
cool but it's definitely not the hardest
thing and well like allows you to make
progress on those projects just internal
motivation like wanting to do it I think
the what's always helpful is just
imagine imagine yourself in ten years
and like look back Oh interesting and
then just use that as a metric for like
what you wanna would you be proud of
yourself for having done that that's
usually someone like that the Beezus
framework of like you know when you're
sixty and you kind of look back on your
life yeah that's interesting but then
but it's dude it's like who's to say
what's gonna lead to the next thing
that's great so like you know alright so
before we did the podcast like I was
talking about working at the onion right
right and now I'm here yeah and you're
like that's not a standard trajectory
braid so you can't really say
authoritative ly like the best way to
spend your time is X but when I when I
was a kid someone said to me like before
you start working on something think
about what winning looks like and that's
kind of a framework for projects for me
oh that's interesting
um but I don't know it's a lot of
personal thing
what other like hawks and motivations
like do you have in your arsenal
I just don't spend time with people that
annoy me or like stressed me out okay
yeah that's a positive thing I
uh I'm never busy but I am fine using
that excuse oh never busy I always have
time for my friends and like the things
I really want to do and I just got
everything else out so I don't know how
about you mmm hacks and motivations um I
think I always want to keep the baseline
pretty pretty low like kind of you know
like yeah like I think like you can you
can control like your output but you can
really control like how the world
responds to it so it's kind of like if
you're just like alright how you could
output them like that's great and then
like however they're all responds like
can't control it but like like being
really happy when you do something you
can control is I think probably the
biggest like mental hack for did I mean
usually you just can't control it's so
hard cuz you're you're still pretty yeah
how old are you 24 yeah yeah so I
remember when I just moved out here I am
how old were you then
23 oh just come out of college sure yeah
so what happened was um I was in New
York for college and then I lived there
for like a couple years afterwards and
my girlfriend and I split up and I was
like I'd always wanted to live in
California and New York whistling and so
I just moved out here oh wow which has
been cool and so when I did you have a
job or something I just like moved out
so the onion moved from New York to
Chicago and almost everyone left and so
I started a company with my friends oh
and we were doing these hackathons where
developers and comedians made stuff
together and it's like a that it was a
total not startup total small business
super fun yeah and we did one with
Twitter and so I moved out here for that
thinking I would be out here for like
months right now it's like whatever six
years later but what about California
was like so different for you that you
had to stay here well I love doing
outdoor stuff for sure okay but it's a
trade I don't know everyone wants to
talk [ __ ] both ways and it's totally a
trade culturally it's not the same thing
as New York but then it's all working in
like tech this is where or entertainment
stuff I mean New York's kind of mixed
but there's la it just seems so much so
much more professional not in like the
polish sense yeah like everyone is or
like most people are here and that's
cool that was cool to me like going to
these like you know coffee shops and
seeing you know this person that I only
seen on the internet before like man all
this shit's happening here that's
interesting but I don't know how do you
think also sorry anyone I like too how
do you know change like in the past
seven years or I guess has it been seven
years for you or something like that
yeah
what has been the biggest thing that's
changed like I got it both positive or
negatively or neutrally in myself or and
I in like the environment that you've
seen from like oh yeah that's super yeah
Tech is completely vilified that's been
the biggest no interesting yeah yeah I
mean it's like if it's not this next
election it's the one afterwards like
tech is the evil thing interesting and
what did you see what drove that are
kind of um hmm well in some ways it's
like an incredible amount of wealth
being accrued to a small amount of
people they're young and I think their
amount of power is just off-putting to
so many folks Oh obviously with the
Facebook thing
Gerard like you have like the person to
vilify and it just feels like the new
banker to me and that's the yes that's
been the shift I'm not a great
precedence because I have you noticed
anything um honestly I think it's kind
of had like in bio is just you know
donor if his attention to Pike oh yeah
we're just all the way over here kind of
like you know working on things that
take a really long time they're very
like hardened expensive it's a people I
go yeah they're still over there like
still working on drugs and side up I
don't think as much and they're like
very few weirdly there are very people
in tourism biotech I think this song
that was very making to me when I first
came out it sort of like I was looking
for people who were amazing and also
made like a lot of capital and by things
like those of people who like wouldn't
be successful and like know how to build
business as well this was my thought and
there were very few of them a lot of
them were in VC hmm would invest in
these companies I was like where the
founder is not getting the capital that
like how does that equation work and I
think
was like a former salesman I was like
the most and forward he ever had about
steel he was just like so I wonder like
how do you sell a business or an idea
I'm like you know you know for my my
cheeks like you know complicated like we
a textbook about it and like right and
he was like you just sit the person down
and tell them what to do okay
I think I understand how this like whole
area of like life you know like what how
to communicate better that I did
previously yeah I really hope more of
these companies I mean they're they are
popping up already like you've seen a
longevity biotech and if there is any
kind of lull in the ecosystem it's just
gonna be like fertile ground what I
think there was like there's been
historically a lack of like founder of
different companies yeah I'm like
obviously the fun environment has
changed to make the like more likely to
happen like the next couple years yeah
but it's just so striking like it really
is different really how like because you
I think if you look like the wealth
created intact and in biotech it's like
really see the distribution you know
going so much more to venture capital I
think min to founders and that was just
that some like really those are really
weird thing to kind of like observer
about like first coming ever so like why
is that the case it's your different
terms than normal PC phones well I mean
I for for our funds yeah I mean if
that's a like a strong opinion you have
like what are your terms
yeah well quite often is like you know
we have h1 so you know so much what you
folks are working on like you know that
that's founder driven that seek you know
I sort of trying to get people you know
sort of leg up and and promote kind of
like Brad since pushed locks as the
founders bears the company like not try
to replace them yeah I guess like like
kind of on some other firms which i
think is a you know a fair strategy if
like that's you know sort of you know
something that that's been your bulwark
like decades but um I mean I think
marketers would say it's someone what's
happened in software like you know you
had this first wave of kind of like
professional managers you're kind like a
swing back technologists you can like a
swing back to the middle of K like now
we'd like some more managers please like
you know still technologists archiving
the show I think if I would might be
kind of like midway through that we're
kind of like we've had like the managers
period for a long time we might have
more technologists and then like maybe
kind of like swing back to the middle
that's like a pretty simple time match
like you who is what really happen in
the future
hmm yeah because the that's interesting
if it's a trailing thing from software
because you probably knows well yeah so
what's happened now is like maybe ten
years ago or when why she started it was
incredibly rare for you to be able to
just like
an idea exactly yeah you can usually do
that but yeah more importantly you can I
mean I hear crazy numbers from people
leaving college and going to work at
Facebook yapanese and then I think
that's like overall probably bad for the
ecosystem be out like it encourages this
like extreme risk aversion right and I
think the likelihood of lifestyle
inflation and never starting something
is high but think about so what enabled
YC right aw yeah AWS from the outside a
huge part of it really the the
first-ever ability driven by tooling to
kind of spend something up really
cheaply and I think in bio and it's like
wouldn't talk to us really like you know
there really was this point where like
you know drop in cost of sequencing has
been occurring over the past like you
know eighteen years but really up to
collect the past three or four years you
could not get a thousand-dollar genome
right like that is a recent phenomenon
and so what argument would be like you
know look at like aluminous revenues you
know like today it's absolutely crazy
how someone they are like Intel's
revenues like right in the 1970s or like
the parallel there is like excuse me
this is jus like you know a friend of
mine nature like notice that's be kind
of like either there's just like this
realist rating parlor which in like that
enables technology that we kind of see
you know in kind of like 1:1 treatment
and they kinda like what's happening
Bauer today and who knows what'll happen
in future but there is an interesting
parallel there hmm huh would you think
there are people in labs
well actually like what percentage of
people working in labs you think want to
start companies so this is the
fascinating thing so we were we were
figure so that's cuz if you look at the
amount of funding that's available on a
venture side to go into biotech in the
past couple years yeah it's insanely
maybe it's doubled tripled in the past
couple years alone but the number of
companies funded has stayed fairly
constant and so we're looking at this
like what the heck is happening here
right and what's happen is like the
number on the top and I like the median
hasn't even changed it's like the top
out of court like the cop-caller
companies are getting more capital per
company that's like Oh less capital has
come from LPS because you've seen like
you know the the Nasdaq piping indexing
you go for like stagnant you know
capital 2011 like monotonically
increasing it's different a small dip
and then like where do you put all this
capital there are no more companies to
invest in and so we were like well why
poor people on certain companies we went
and talked like a hundred grad students
and postdocs and the actually gave us
was
like absolutely striking it was like
most of them so it may be like you know
10% reputation risk like we didn't want
to leave film and go back 80% had never
thought about the idea of starting a
company they just were not aware that
there was no a possibility and so you
could argue okay maybe that's like
they're not entrepreneurial but you know
if you think about like you know and
then 80s or the 90s like would you have
God as a CSU at Stanford like started
something maybe but maybe you'd have a
lot higher but barriers or bar to doing
that right any that's part of why she
started I think that process easier hmm
and so I think really Wilson's lack of
education you know and kind of like just
availability options these people which
is like it makes you so angry right like
you know like you should never be forced
or kind of like convince you something
you don't want to or that's not good for
you well you you should be aware of your
options like how are always smart people
not aware of like all the possibilities
that are out there for them I mean it's
I think the saddest / funniest one I've
heard is when someone often in lay a
hard science like lab or background they
learned about YC and then think that
we're just giving them loans and they're
like oh no I can never do that
yeah we're just like I mean I don't know
if you had no exposure to this like why
wouldn't you think that would be like
and all of these myths exist but I think
the education thing is a good point for
the most part people don't even know
that's obviously crazy yeah so you
should talk about your I mean do you
have dude you have so many questions but
you should also maybe mention your
project Daniel if because yes yes yeah
so I'm super excited so and my friend
Daniel grow started this really really
awesome sort of project called pioneer
and and what pioneer is is it's trying
to find like the Lost Einsteins of the
world everything is like an awesome
tagline yeah and you know I think Danny
has a fascinating background in that
like he you know was kind of on track to
join like these really are me and then
you know uploaded I kind of a solution
to YC and and you know like basically
like his whole life changed after like
one flight out here and in meeting with
like you know Paul Graham and Co sort of
like this you know he's almost
incredible successful person but kind of
like you know would he have had the same
chance if and off like a lucky you know
I think his dad forged him like an
article about like see like that was how
I found out about it right really I
don't know
I mean that I don't get this one the one
thing you miss is like this coincidence
that kind of drove his journey and so
the question is like you know how many
people are there out there that like
it's a small intervention could like you
know drastically have like a different
life course and so pioneer pioneer app
is this place where if you're anybody in
the role and you have a project you want
to work on you can apply it could be
anything anywhere from kind of like I
want to have more my high school friends
do you like science stuff all the way
through to like I'm 80 and I finally
want to write my novel and you know you
there's a thing called the Pioneer
tournament where people work for about
30 days you kind of you know do their
projects and kind of like the community
votes like on they're kind of like most
kind of you know favorite people and I
kind of based on that at the end you
know a set of people expected to like be
flown in San Francisco you receive about
like a five thousand dollar grants and
they kind of like join the pyre in
community which is kinda like this you
know set up really ambitious Outsiders
trying to change the world and so I
resonate it's because like you know my
personal story was coming from New
Zealand at age twelve you know based on
like a random email I sent to like a
professor here and it was the first
thing Landover sent to like someone was
on I found a number and she responded
but if she hadn't responded and like
that luck hadn't occurred and like you
know where would I be I have no idea
yeah and so that's why I think it just
like Pienaar so exciting because it
might help a lot and everyone who's like
you should definitely definitely apply
pirate on tap did you know I think it
unlocks so much potential but everyone
in the world who like could be doing
awesome things I think it's so cool
yeah just enabling people to like have
the the confidence thing has been the
biggest surprise for me oh I see well
interesting I think a huge unspoken part
of white YC is successful is that it
gives people the confidence to do their
thing rates and they're often like I
mean sometimes it's insider you know
like tracked like I went to Stanford
whatever but sometimes it's like total
outsider people and it works out and I
think that like Hamet without systems
that give people that that little extra
push a lot of people will never do it
how interesting it is yeah I mean it's
crazy like because I do these office
hours occasionally with people who are
interested in applying right and they're
awesome they're great and all it takes
is like that one meeting we're just like
you're good enough you can do it and
it's it that's so and then they apply
huh
crazy yeah I mean I think one of the
fascinating things that the dining
center own interests were like how do
you give that to like how do you scale
that feeling of like transmitting
confidence I was like you know that's
non-trivial well you asked me about
podcast before we started right and so
this is like a yeah crazy side effect of
podcasting because it it makes you feel
and the thing it makes you feel like you
know someone really well but the reality
is you kind of do
and so that like that relationship of
someone as like whatever just like
friend or mentor or whatever huh is
enough to be like oh like I kind of get
this I can be myself with them and I can
kind of just like express whatever I
want to do but then there are totally
like weird elements for me like I'll be
like in the bathroom it literally and
like someone who like tapped me on the
back and really oh man oh I can podcast
like it cool not do people feel like
they know you from hearing so many of
your conversations with others and kind
of like how you think about the world I
guess like cuz you said that one thing
that you find fasting is like how all
the people think about the world yeah I
think it's like the way that you ask
questions must give some information
about how you build models or few
systems or her stupid I am
yeah I mean I I don't talk a ton about
myself
I mean I do but yeah people get the
sense and I was actually thinking about
talking to my friend about this this
morning of like what is it about the how
am i different on the podcast first in
real life because there's there's like
some distance for both of us right
there's like gonna be some dissonance
there right and I'm curious about like
how to best merge the two and I haven't
figured it out yet cuz I actually don't
know what the what the gap is
it's you don't know what your I was I
was about to text a man I didn't and
uh-huh yeah I mean you seem pretty kind
of like on the surface similar
but yeah I guess it would be hard to
know without beautiful so have you
listened to before
no just the constantly are situated
conversation before we started that kind
of like oh right basically the same
thing yeah maybe huh interesting yeah I
don't know I mean it'd be better if you
were more like the person that you like
yeah like what what authenticity do you
think would would bring like that like
we don't have kind of now curious so in
some ways I'm just selfishly interested
in like making it something that feels
more like me and it's not it's my thing
right
you're always curious about like gains
you know what can make this show better
right and when I think about the
podcasts that I like you know things
like Rogen stuff like that I mean I'm
like that's not fringe but I imagine and
this is again like projecting cuz I've
never hung out with him I imagine that
it's like very close to what hanging out
with the person is like and then when I
watch the podcast and me sometimes I can
tell that I'm nervous or not it's like I
don't know natural that's normal do
think it's the environment like if you
if you made this like feel like you're
living in many different er um yeah it's
possible yeah it's totally but I mean I
think one thing that would be beneficial
it's like hanging I mean you're this is
you know you're great so it's like very
chilled it's very easy yeah but
sometimes like hanging out with someone
beforehand
oh I see so if you have a conversation
and then it just continues into yeah and
in the my desire to keep it like on
topic we can make it less natural than
it could be rates that makes sense yeah
you know I mean yeah you always come
back to like one thing but then maybe
like that's not actually that the
organic way that I would have fun right
because I mean like what actually this
would be a good test because I'll put
this one out and people like dude what
the [ __ ]
and topic with the longevity stuff yeah
I don't know yeah the only interesting I
don't know it's tough because you are
you a podcast person I actually am not
like I really only do books and papers
because pluck eyes are kind of annoying
like you can't fast forward they didn't
easily and kind of use your eyes like
figure out like they were transcribed
then I might read them but yeah would
you can I would some do we do
but not everyone then I also feel like I
don't I think there's like something
about DBT croix but you know if
everyone's new to the same podcasts and
you go and like spend the same amount of
time reading like for like the Greeks
kind of you know what the cities was
thinking you might have like very
outdated information that's like not
very informed you know about today but
you also might like I guess get a
similar feel for how somebody was but
have it be like more decorrelated and
therefore um ideally kind of like more
on sort of like get maybe like a better
a few point than the normal I think you
should
I think tightly I mean dude the amount
of times I've heard people reference
sapiens or Charlie Munger he's like I
just can't deal I mean I they're great
they're awesome ideas whatever right
like everyone's consuming the same media
yeah and I think it's like if you if you
don't and you try to understand it from
first principles which I think's like me
for as well as itself thing like kind of
like I think there's often sided it's
like the good thing maybe not fully
understood you look quite different I
think one thing most people really it's
like you know math and science often are
like more artistic than they are kind of
like logical but like everyone's trying
to like frame things like a logical
process so yeah well cuz it's I think a
counterintuitive thing is that you well
I mean it's obvious when you say it out
loud to pursue an idea in math or
science you have to be inspired to
pursue it because you don't know if it's
true beforehand
exactly exactly no it's so crazy like I
think it's fast like you look at Newton
right like noon Spence
he had like it's amazing you're when
he's 21 he like to scores all these
things and then he wasn't like alchemy
in the Bible and you're like what like
where does that come from but I think
part of it is like the crime II
obviously it's a logical and analytical
like is these like books were so curious
but I think also like he has some kind
of like
a little bit like a missus isn't like
this kind of these weird-ass but defends
like a little bit artistic we kind of
like we forget that we're like oh yeah
like scientists are kind of like robots
but they're they're really yeah they're
really not definitely not definitely all
right so let's actually get some of
these questions
so which ones appealed to you because we
have so many I think the ones that are
like factual orchids so just like the
the research questions probably do that
so maybe we should rip through because
I'm genuinely interested in a lot of
these and I've read I read your
longevity FAQ which is awesome it's very
like um Tim urban wait but why style
I mean it's the drawings that got me
yeah but that was cool well yeah yeah
that must have taken a lot of work yeah
it's like you know just drawing the kind
of like axes and then like three Lyons's
yeah so Samba Tesh s do you think
there's gonna be another step function
change in human span yeah since you know
germ theory what's the next one I think
this is a super fascinating question and
time to be alive because like you know
you know it really it's fascinating you
look back and kind of like you know germ
theory just like such a huge
breakthrough
I think but one thing I think is lost
also is like there's another
breakthrough that's similar related
which is that like life comes from life
yeah
obviously for all history we think that
like there's spontaneous generation of
life like literally up into like you
know right about that time and in fist
years like nope nope nope like you know
these germs are coming in like these
like the neck of the pipe it's not and
so you know that and that was just you'd
break through and then I you know
obviously Darwin kind of also very
important I think the thing that we kind
of have an intuition will be important
in longevity that most people are kind
of not paying attention to is like what
it it's gonna sound way too
philosophical but really when you get
into it I think it's the important thing
what does it mean to be alive
um and at what point are you kind of
differentiating between like the germ
line which is kind of like your
reproductive cells and the soma which is
kind of like your kind of scant issue
because there is a immortal line of kind
of like living kind of thing
that has some replicating sins like our
first ancestor right transmitted through
our germline when I have a kid that kid
does not come out and like how they seem
out of Aging that I do when I have it
it's kind of like brand-new right and
like how the heck does that happen and
how do you fit that kind of paradigm
like if you take for example a bacterium
now there's some bacteria do
asymmetrically divided and like possibly
have some form of aging but kind of like
you know do you look at a bacterium and
things like that that thing is aging
maybe maybe not and so what is it about
multi alert and kind of like our
germline and assume and the
differentiation between the two that's
caused us to kind of evolve or start
this kind of like aging phenomenon and
you've given that is it natural or can
we think about how our desire to kind of
like live longer ourselves fits into
kind of like that differentiation
because you know Nature has already
solved for kind of weak living forever
on some level right on the cell level
and so kind of what is it about yeah our
so my that like is so different and and
are there anything that we can repurpose
and use you know for that and so I think
that that area is gonna be super super
fasting and then I've also just broadly
in love with question like what is life
right kinda like that is so interesting
like you know Schroedinger like the
1930s can like writing it's fascinating
tracks like bringing like Maxwell Park
and others in and so that you know that
and kind of people thinking about it
like you know sort of Germany England
um Umit or just absolutely incredible in
their work that that it's re a longer
answer like you know we just think like
I love this question starlight you know
we spend so much time people like the
practicalities but kind of like the
higher level order of like will be the
actual break thing I think about like
that that are just like really
interesting sort of tangent you
mentioned yep giving birth right is
someone working I mean I some someone
but like are people working on extending
fertility windows if you expand health
spend because that seems like you know
if you could live forever
brace as a dude like I can just opt out
right all right I'm not gonna have kids
or we're not gonna like in my mind
that's the real issue right it's like
allocating time yeah you know so if we
say you work aggressively until you're
30
yeah or 35 or whatever and then you have
kids like all a sudden you have to take
care of this thing or will die right um
so being able to push that till you're
sixty yep seems like really valuable yep
well well so we think that's that's that
is
and so he was a fascinating to me times
Italy where there's a fascinating area
because you know there are some animals
many in fact where like you know you
have some octopi that lay their age and
then their mouth disappears and they
like sitting on their bags and like
really commit suicide and if you reverse
like glandular action like gives rise to
that they just keep on living and so
it's like you have programs in essence
all over the animal kingdom and like
we're you know anthropocentric humans so
we say that doesn't happen to us but if
you think about menopause rightly didn't
woman like what is that that is a
clocked acute onset I've kind of lock of
loss of health right not as fertility
like many other things you get fat
redistribution you like you know bone
loss acutely at the time of menopause so
many of the things get like a lot worse
in a clocked fashion you kind of look at
other animals over like that yeah but
really are we that different and some
that areas just and there's this
importance that we're looking to right
now that are involved in that process
that we're super fasting for longevity
and so any like that area is just yes
really really interesting so would yeah
I mean is it more I imagine it's more
likely for it to be an artificial womb
than reengineering humans but maybe
that's not one that we never look at
cancer like not you know if you solved
that problem when it's just like so long
you have any problem right um but I
think there's actually you know that
would be cool but like even just
thinking about like what is menopause
yeah
right because like you yeah why is it so
times like what does the clock that like
turns on and if we like turn off that
clock like would it push backward is
there some kind of natural and there's
some like obvious answers for that but
um I you know it just it really is and
you think of like how did evolution
decide like that was a correct time and
so that I think that it was like yeah
interesting all right Jason Choi asks
what's the percentage of longevity
attributable to lifestyle choices versus
genetics and the progress of technology
and influencing both oh interesting
there's a recent paper that actually
came out super fast nice guy you gotta
need air lick in science and what it did
was they have a public database of
heredity so basically a family tree
unfortunately doesn't have actual
genomic data for each person but you
have a lot of lifespan data so age of
birth and ends or death dates many
generations back and so you can ask what
is the kind of like um
heritability of longevity you know if
your parents lived longer are you also
likely
longer and I think part that we've had
about a 25% heritability kind of figure
I think that drops you like about 11
percent I could be off on this figure
but I think that paper was about 11
percent um could be wrong and so that I
think that's kind of the current
statement from the field is that like
that's you know our prior like
percentage along jyoti people genetics I
think that underestimates a potential
package I can tell you because we're
like you know do you have kind of like
um you know mutants that are like long
live and the population no and so maybe
you know I think doesn't tell you like
how much genes could be changed
influence longevity yeah 11 percent
would be like the current estimate from
the field
hmm okay Fatih asks is blood transfusion
so this is para biases yeah is it a
thing or just oh gosh no I did the blood
boy question oh yeah the blood boys are
like are they false around everywhere we
go we're asking all the blood boy sub so
one thing that's fascinating right is
like him if you go back and ask what are
the first-ever things discovered to
impact longevity you know the tools that
we had prior to 1950 did not allow us to
do genetics they did all on the muck of
their level they don't deny us like any
of the things that we now kind of become
longevity the one thing that Alex Carell
in 1912 gets the Nobel Prize for sewing
blood vessels together and so what does
one of things that has tried and it
would be early half like the 20th
century because like that's the only
thing that we have the tools to do it's
like literally like you know you're like
you're sewing loves together between
young and old Mouse yeah and that does
appear to have positive impacts you know
they're three or four patron science
papers are come out recently showing you
know there's some positive impact on
kind of like the function of the brain
some positive impact on function on the
hearts some one muscle we do see
positive impacts I haven't seen to date
a really good longevity study so I think
we've seen a lot of evidence of like
age-related kind of phenotypes getting
better yeah but I personally not seem to
say that like really you know makes me
super excited about kind of like the
number of extra years lots of stuffs
like indicated that might be the case if
done correctly but just I actually
haven't seen that study you know like
sort of done yes there's been some
studies published like in the mid
nineteen hundreds about pair biases and
I think I might have cited that kind of
indicate an exception but they're kind
of like really replicated properly to
really believe that and so I think that
you know there's
some type of ice bag like I don't think
we have that full characterized yet hmm
okay so true like not a hoax not works
by relate preference I think people
really over focus on that because it's
such an easy story to tell right like
vampire vampire like you know 60
different things that make you acts live
longer and like you have to look at the
notes but people don't hear but like - -
insulin receptor I'll you won't hear
about like vampires yeah no I mean it's
just like kind of what I was saying
before about like tech being seen as
black and white like sort of like
everything people just want the pill oh
actually I wanted to talk about
rapamycin ah yeah so my friend Nicola
wrote a New Yorker article about it Oh
awesome
I'm like I'm slightly terrified race but
can you can you just break it down I'm
soso rapamycin is this is this really
really interesting drug discovered on
Rapa Nui the aisle in a soil sample yeah
many made drugs were and you know kind
of what it does is many things but but I
think one thing that's been focused on
is impact on what's called mTOR which is
a protein that's part of kind of two
different call boxes of proteins and so
you know the problem iciness have a lot
of kind of like side effects right it's
originally developed like you know maybe
I mean suppressant in one use and so do
you really want to be taking about like
you know continuously probably not um
there's a lot of doctors you know if you
ask kind of like a subset of kind of
people who specialize in crazy things
that might actually work in longevity if
you then will say like pull strap and
license or taking your Meissen and very
kind of you know huge doses but then
like on a schedule and what continuously
is a good thing yeah and I think that
like we don't see that like being
disproven or like implausible it can
like it is I think a risky endeavor on
some level one thing I would say is you
know we there are several companies
trying to develop much safer versions
that do the same things like have the
positive benefit like don't have like
all the other kind of like I'm sort of
negative negative effects and so I
person was kinda like wait until those
like it a little bit farther along but I
mean it Rock'em Ison is kind of report I
think the funny thing is like I don't
think I have a great feeling for what
the max is on the licensure that's
possible without my sin
like the question is like if you dose it
up like what's the maximum dose and how
at what point you starting at like
decreasing returns longevity it's
awfully that we've actually hit that
barrier quite well um
the other fascinating Lake sort of thing
interesting what about them I've heard
people taking testosterone and like that
really maybe it increases health span
but it really might shortened lifespan
no week we had a lot and there's a lot
going like we're in a loti society he
was also I think what people ting growth
hormone you know for longevity yeah and
when I first when I first saw that
income like an airplane magazine I was
furious because like in worms if you do
if you like knock out the analog of
growth hormone receptor they live longer
and and you know mice like dwarf mice
are the long live mice and like within a
species not you know between threes but
within a species you know being smaller
was actually a correlate with longevity
um but I think you know one thing there
is like maybe taking with hormone makes
an eight-year-old feel a lot better it's
kinda like a healthspan
optimization so back to that kind of
like you know do you feel better like
that was long ago Iseman but I don't
think that's a great thing obviously to
do kind of like actual lifespan
yeah because to clarify it can incur
increase or encourage like cancer cell
growth I mean there's this possible some
minor thing there but I think for the
most part there's a not fully defined
complexing pathway that seems to kind of
be quite related to longevity yeah that
was first discovered in worms and and
then kind of like also categorizing
humans like there's a subset of dwarfs
for example who appear to compare to
their relatives suffer much less cancer
metabolic disease and that correlate to
what you expect from mice like if you
mutate mice yeah to feed Orff's they
live about sixty percent longer than
normal like 60 percent sweet on trophy
solid race
how much shorter would you be if you can
live 60% oh I'm not quite sure I don't
know it's not like ten percent obviously
but like you know between 50 and 70 but
but but I or 80 I'm not actually sure
for those mice how much more they were
contentedly
but I think maybe you can actually
possibly D correlate like the Bing
smaller math effect just like not not
just like a slice he's like the only
thing as well hmm would you make that
trade if you're like oh the trait is
positive so the idea is like you can you
can decouple like the being smaller like
longevity benefits I know you would you
yeah probably
probably yeah so RB de Grey another like
kind of famous longevity person someone
asked about them so Chris asks he's
mentioned several times about replacing
organs with new organic ones before they
fail is that a reasonable idea or would
they more likely be replaced with
synthetic ones Oh interesting
I think so this is an area that we're
still building our it's like maybe too
late to be like seven years and still
pieces building yeah but it I you know I
think there there are so many things
that have to go right for that to become
like the obvious thing to do you know I
mean in some ways like the oldest
version of aging right not like you know
back to our friend Alex Carell and is no
price well like you know he is doing the
first ever kind of like sewing up kind
of like the organs and kind of like
let's get it you know a little a few
vias paper that's like let's just grab
this like dog kidney and like we'll take
this one for this other dog like you
know plug it in and he's just in your
like welcome that's the early eighteen
hundreds so in a sense what Arbor is
proposing is the oldest most kind of
like worked on idea but then you know I
I think we also we just haven't seen
that's done well on the rejuvenation
front a lot recently and I think I don't
I think we're still on it you know
there's something's really if you get it
organ for somebody who's had cancer for
example it look as smaller it's like ten
years later you might also incur come
kind of negative events and things like
that I think I think we're still
understanding kind of how to weigh those
those risks but I think about seems a
it's a surprising fact that it is you
know it sounds the most futuristic but
it's actually the most kind of like old
method of kind of like considering
working in the space right well you're
just like take the part out put it
another way to go yep yeah all right so
I'm a very important question so Micah
said you did a cookie diet is that true
yes yeah how do I go I think was pretty
informative in that you know again I
would recommend anybody like go just
cookies but we're these like fancy
health food cookies you know so is the
reason I did it was my friend had
claimed that he had only eaten whipped
cream and bacon for a month and that
this was possible yeah all right but
then he was like but I actually feel
pretty good too and I thought that it
was hope yes and that he probably mean
he's a very smart and like you know
conscious person I was like well like
either he's like very different than I
really thought it was or that's possible
to do and
I wanted to test it so I tried that and
it's like well you actually kind of can
and you kind of feel fine um it's not a
curious if you took any random thing we
can you rent food object like just ate
that for a month like what would happen
and the cookie diet like worked very
well but I just I for the long-term it
seemed like probably not a good idea so
switching off of that like a lower sugar
diets probably good idea did you were
you doing blood tests or rizal by feel
no no I should have done what tests
that's funny yeah there was this
well-known long-distance hiker named
Andrew skorca a bunch of blogs and stuff
and he's a pretty well-known for having
kind of extreme he just has a diet that
can take anything it seems like so he
was like I think for a while it was just
like Snickers and Pringles something
like that that sounds great yeah which I
mean I guess if you have enough
toothpaste like on the Pacific Crest
Trail you're fine yeah you have to go to
warded though it like like how much
worse that would be then like wonderful
examples right I think that like a lot
of for help eating meats maybe the worst
part I mean is like if your animal is
stressed like had like a lot of the in
correction type of hormone directly
before like being killed but actually
looking more important thing like
whether you're eating meat or not sort
of like what that kind of like minor
things are that we don't think about
like the axes that arts like explicit
like what those are but yeah hard to say
cool alright my last question is are you
seriously not doing anything really
weird there's like no pills
there's no weird food there's no crazy
fasting um I mean I think that apart
from trying you know the cookie diet it
was a one thing that I was trying to do
for a while was like I was trying to
quite understand you know because we're
just like black boxes and like you in
take some number of calories and like
you should be able to calculate like
aware of the they all go like how many
are necessary like each day like from
first principles like figure out kind of
like what awful diet would be I tried to
do that for muscle so I was like like
how many proteins should we eat 30
minutes after working out the first
problem was it's really hard like why I
think what's after working out the
correct amount of time no idea because
they're like you know our if cells are
expanding depend of time but like it's
hard to you know figure out um also just
got really down on the weeds of like how
many me know acids would be required to
like replace certain things and and I
think I came out of that kind of like
very convinced like a lot of things that
like people talk about the high level
like wrong and we probably theoretically
like animal or level and that like I
shouldn't have the time to kind of like
really think about Nestle whole time and
so I think at this point until I have
like you know maybe a full year to kinda
like go back and understand that whole
area better um it's kind of like just
you know that obvious thing is because
history is probably like a good teacher
for like you know baseline health nice
alright if someone wants to learn more
about you where should they go yes
so we run longevity fund and I'm just
laura along Toby dot fee C and anyone
can reach out and we love to talk to you
cool thanks for coming in awesome thank
you having me
you